hello my name is Matthew here's my
question for you west coast what do you
think the percentage chances that the
LHC will find a spasm hi Matthew you're
asking what are what odds would I give
for the LHC to find the Higgs boson well
you know I think that the odds are very
good I don't know whether I would place
them at eighty percent ninety percent
it's almost a hundred percent that we
will find if not the traditional symbol
Higgs boson something that plays the
same role more might be a slightly more
complicated but you know the existence
of this particle the Higgs boson is the
last nail in this structure called the
standard model which works exceedingly
well and as well tested just about
everywhere it can be so it almost would
fly in the face of logic and mathematics
if we were not to find the Higgs boson
or some mild variation of it so I'm
pretty confident that in about I it
probably will take five or six years
it's a very difficult particle to
observe in the mass range that its most
likely to be in in about five or six
years will be pretty confident that we
have nailed down the Higgs burglar